[cough]
[laughter] All right, let's move on to a
It looks like this is maybe a question
for Cap. Uh, since Cap couldn't couldn't
answer the question about Adonai, can
you show where the word Adonai has been
used for a creature and not Adon?
Because we know that Adon has been used
for creature. So, don't attack a straw
man.
>> Well, I wasn't attacking the straw man.
That was Sam attacking the straw man.
What my response was, the first response
I gave was that Lord, Adawan, Adon,
Adoni, God are all interchangeable
because you can see angels called that.
I brought up the verse where the house
of David is called that. So just because
you see those words, if I was to go even
further in Chronicles when it says the
Lord uh provoked David to number the
people, you'll see when in 1 Chronicles
21:1 and Satan stood up against Israel.
When you go to First Samuels, you'll see
it was the Lord. So, I didn't take a
straw man. He took a straw man with the
technicality out of out of out of this,
out of that. He did that. I didn't do
that. [laughter]
Listening is an art. I'm done.
>> All right. And speaking the truth and
hearing is an art, too. Now, let me
destroy the argument. Notice he couldn't
show you where Adonai is used for a mere
creature, right? And Lord willing I will
be doing a session on that. But it's not
the argument of adoni. That is used for
many. It's not the argument of adon. We
said adoni and he still couldn't show
you that. And if you go back he said 1st
Samuel 24:8 there it's adoni. It's not.
It's adoni. So either he's ignorant or
he lied. But seeing his track record he
lied. I won't give him the benefit of
the doubt. Moreover, the argument of
sarak 43:26 wasn't that the word there
is Jesus. The argument was that it says
God sustains all things by his word.
Hebrews 1:3 says it's Jesus who sustains
things by his word. Not that Jesus is
the word in Sierak 43, but that God
sustains all things by his word. But it
says Jesus sustains all things by his
word. That mean Jesus is the God most
high who sustains all things by his
word. Means he is the ancient of days.
He is the most high who became flesh,
one with the father and the spirit.
That's why hearing and not lying is an
art too. Cap, put a cap in it.
All right, question for cap. Isaiah 42:8
says, "God will not share his glory. Yet
in John 17:5, Jesus speaks of sharing
the father's glory before the world
existed." Explain this.
>> Gotcha. So this is John 17:5. It says,
"And now, oh father, glorify thou me
with thine own self with the glory which
I had with thee before the world was."
In Isaiah, that was 44 and6. You said
Isaiah 42:8.
>> Got you. So in Isaiah 42 and8, the
reason for the him saying I won't uh
give my glory to another. The rest of
that verse says, "Neither my praise to
graven images." Because the subject in
Isaiah 42 is about them worshiping other
idols as gods. And what the Most High is
saying, I'm not giving my glory like for
example to Baal or Molech or any other
graven image that you have. But in John
17, not only does Christ ask to get the
glory back, but that same glory that he
got, when you go down to verse 22,
it says, "And the glory which thou
gavest me, I have given them
that they may be one even as we are
one." So if the God if the Isaiah 42:8
was specifically talking about God not
giving the glory to nobody else. Not
only did Christ asked for that glory but
then he took that glory and then gave it
to others. So the context can't be the
same in Isaiah 42 and John 17.
>> Yeah. If you want to keep the Bible up
so that it's up to you, right? I mean so
you can leave that screen where you can
see all of us and super chat. Okay.
Number one, the argument wasn't merely
whether the father gives the son glory
and the son gives that glory to the
disciples. What he was saying is this,
which is not said of the disciples. John
17:5. And now, oh father, glorify thou
me with thine own self, but the glory
which I had with thee before the world
was. You cannot show me anywhere in that
chapter where this is said of the
disciples that they had glory alongside
of the father before the creation of the
world. That's number one. Jesus does.
Even in that context when it says the
glory you gave me, I gave to them. It is
not the same glory that Jesus had from
before the world was because if we
continue reading John 17:22 is what he
cited. But John 17:24, "Father, I will
that they also whom thou has given me be
with me where I am, that they may behold
my glory, not the glory I gave them,
which thou has given me, for thou loves
me before the foundation of the world."
So even in that chapter, the glory that
God gave Jesus that he gave to disciples
is not the glory that Jesus had
alongside the father from before the
creation world where the father was
loving on him. And thirdly, to show you
that it's not just the father who's
glorified when people worship Jesus. The
father glorifies Jesus the way Jesus
glorifies him. Here you go. These words,
John 17:1 and2 spake Jesus and lifted up
his eyes to heaven and said, "Father,
the hour has come. Glorify thy son that
thy son also may glorify me." It's
reciprocal. Glorify me that I may
glorify you. Glorify me the way I
glorify you. as thou has given him power
over all flesh that he should give
eternal life to as many as thou has
given him. Again, John 13:31-32,
it is his reciprocal. Therefore, when he
was gone out, Jesus said, "Now is the
son of man glorified and God is
glorified in him." Meaning the son will
bring glory to the father and earth. But
what will the father do? If God be
glorified in him, God shall also glorify
him in himself. And straight away
glorify him. Reciprocal. They glorify
each other equally, which was what we
would expect if they're equals. and not
the same person. John 8:50, "And I seek
not my own glory. There is one that
seeketh and judgeth. One demands that I
be glorified and will judge you if you
don't." Who is that? John 8:54. Jesus
answered, "If I honor myself, my honor
is nothing. It is my father that honorth
me." God the Father honors me and
demands that you glorify me and honor me
with the same honor he receives. That
shows you he must be equal in divinity
and glory and majesty, though not the
same person. All must honor the son as
they honor the father. That's the
destruction of your cold brother. Time
to repent. Come to the true Jesus
because your god doesn't exist. He can't
save you.
>> All right,
>> you're muted again, s I can't hear you,
Cameron.
>> Sorry, guys. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Um,
all right. So, we got another question
for Sam. Uh Sam, how are you the first
born of creation but have no beginning?
Clearly that's a beginning. By the way,
this is our uh we're going to do two
more questions and then close out.
>> Yeah, I was about to say, yep, about two
more.
>> That's we could be I thought we were
supposed to be concise, too. That man
just went in a whole diet trial.
>> Well, you hold on to be fair. One, let's
try to be concise about a couple of
minutes, but thank you. I appreciate it.
One of the questions he took a couple of
minutes. That's very easy. You
>> want me to answer the question, brother?
You still My goodness. I know you got
cremated, but take that easy, man.
The word firstborn.
>> Okay, I'm trying, brother. See, I love
you, Cameron. A man, he's right about
the white man. Dude, shoot. The word
firstborn doesn't mean the first
>> say nothing about the white man.
>> Even though he just said white rag and
all that, take it easy, big boy. Take it
easy. The word go against, hey, muzzle
your mouth. That demon in you. Shh. Let
me get here, bro. You got a cult meeting
to go and lead to their destruction. May
Jesus save them from you. The word
firstborn doesn't always mean firstborn
one created. How do we know? Because in
Psalm 89:19 to20. Then thou spakest in
vision to thy holy one and said, I have
laid help upon one that is mighty. I
have exalted one chosen out of the
people. I found David my servant with my
holy oil have I anointed him. And here
he says of David, he shall cry unto me,
thou art my father, my God, and the rock
of my salvation. Also, I will make him
my firstborn, higher than the kings of
the earth. David wasn't the first son
born, nor was he the first king of
Israel. Firstborn means supreme,
preeminent, superior to all the other
kings. That's the meaning here in
Colossians 1. Firstborn of all creation,
meaning he is supreme in status and in
power over creation because it explains
it. Firstborn of every creation. Why?
Because for by him were all things
created that are in heaven that are in
earth visible and invisible whether they
be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers. All things
were created by him for him. I challenge
kept to show a single verse in the Old
Testament where a creature alongside of
God is set to be the one who created all
things because that would be a
contradiction. Did he create himself? He
is before all things. Meaning he is
timeless and was there when no creation
existed. By him all things consist.
That's no creature. That's the
firstborn. Meaning the one who supreme
over all creation because he creates it,
sustains it, and governs it. That means
he's the most high according to Isaiah
44:24. Yahawasha.
>> Yeah, I won't be as long-winded as him.
And you could tell when somebody's
getting beat when they asking a question
in the Q&A question. He asking me a
question. In Revelations 3 and 12, when
it says um I'm sorry, 3 and 8, where is
it? 3 and 14. It says, "And unto the
angel of the church of the loudians,
write these things saith the ammon, the
faithful and true witness, the beginning
of the creation of God." Why is that
important? Because in a lot of cases,
firstborn has nothing to do with being
literal. Uh he referenced David. You can
also go to um Israel themselves when uh
Exodus 4:22 and it says Israel as my
son, even my firstborn. So obviously
Israel was the youngest nation born. So
it's not literal. But when it comes to
Christ saying the beginning of the
creation of God, we have to take his
word for it because no matter where we
put Christ at, he is not before the
ancient of days. And if the ancient of
days is called the ancient of days and
Christ is not ancient, that means that
there was a time when Christ was not
there. And if I just skip up two verses,
let's see what Christ continued to say
out of his own mouth. Him that
overcomemeth will I make a pillar in the
temple of my God. Hold up. Christ said,
temple of my God, and he shall go no
more out, and I would write upon him the
name of my God. Now, he said early in
the debate that Yahawah is Christ's
name, but Christ just said he's going to
write upon him the name of his God. In
the name of the holy city of my God,
which is New Jerusalem, which come down
of heaven from my God. In Revelations 3
and 12, just one verse, Christ said he
had a God one, two, three, four times.
I'm done,
>> man. You said you weren't going to be
long-winded and look at you.
>> I wasn't. I read two verses. I read
[laughter] two verses. This man read
like 12.
But I'll take this last question. I'll
extend my time because I did say
>> Yeah, I'll take one more question.
>> Okay. Okay. Sorry about that. Yeah. One.
All right. One more. Um question for
cap. Who created all things? Isaiah
44:24 says, "The Most High made all
things by himself." And John 13 and
Hebrews 1:10 says, "Jesus created all
things." So who created all things?
>> He created all things. That's why I like
the verse that I read earlier, 1
Corinthians 8:6. The father gets the
credit for everything. So I always use
simple examples. We'll say Moses
delivered the children of Israel, but
we'll also say God delivered the
children of Israel. God parted the Red
Sea. Even though we know Moses was the
man that he used to do it. So when it
comes to creation of everything outside
of Christ,
um God told Christ to do it and Christ
did it. See, that was that was brief.
That wasn't long-winded at all. brief.
>> Okay, now share my screen, brother, if
you can because we're gonna go out with
a bang.
>> Look, this ain't going to be brief. Th
This ain't going to be brief.
>> Don't whine, brother. You can leave if
you want because it's your funeral.
>> I'm not whining. I'm being funny.
>> Can I get to the verse? You're running
out of time, dude. Take it easy. Thus
sayeth the Lord, thy redeemer, and he
that formed thee from the womb. I am the
Lord that maketh all things. Now, guys,
watch. The Lord made all things that
stretch forth the heavens alone. He
didn't have anyone helping him. that
spreadth apart the earth by myself
didn't have anyone helping him. Job 98,
which alone spreadth out the heavens,
and treadth upon the ways of the sea.
It's not about creation. He did it all
alone. You cannot have Jesus being a
creature of the father when we're told
in Colossians 1:13-17,
who is the image of his visible God,
first one of every creature. For by him
were all things created. If we follow
his logic, it should have said all other
things because all things means the
entire creation. For the son to be used
to create the entire creation, that
means he's not part of creation. What
don't you get? That's 1 Corinthians 8:6.
One Lord by whom all things were. What
don't you get? Revelation 5:13. Every
creature in all of creation separate
from the lamb and worships the lamb the
way they worship the father. What don't
you get? He is before all things, not
all other things. Only God is before all
things. So the son is not created. He's
as old as the father because he's the
ancient of days. The most high father
became flesh. That's why the father
still is God because he's still in the
flesh. Bye-bye to your cult and your
fate god. Time for you to repent before
you end up the feet of the most high
Jesus, your God and judge. Christ is
Lord most high one with the father and
spirit. Amen.